Ron DeSantis has just dropped a single
digits in New Hampshire very very bad
news for the governor Trump right now in
New Hampshire is at 43 percent no other
candidate comes close uh DeSantis and
Chris Christie actually tie for second
place the reason this is so brutal for
DeSantis is that the DeSantis Mojo was
based largely on The View that he could
win the primary and the general he's the
only candidate who can beat Trump in the
primary and he's a candidate much better
positioned to defeat Joe Biden in the
general that was the argument yes the
campaign was premised on him being a
good Governor yes the campaign was
premised on him doing well with donors
yes the campaign was premised on him
having a clear political Vision he's got
all those things the the main factor
here when you're talking about going up
against Donald Trump who's running
effectively as an incumbent is that he
could win so the moment that it seems
that DeSantis can't win it's not just
that his campaign is gradually going to
drop her up drop a little bit it's going
to start to drop precipitously as we
have already seen